americans are being bled dry at the gas
pump and the high energy prices are not
only emptying our wallets but also
driving up the cost of virtually
everything else that we purchase
these high energy prices are directly
attributable to decisions that joe biden
has made decisions on oil pipelines
decisions on domestic energy production
decisions on russia and ukraine but
never mind all that the white house is
claiming victory because gas prices
declined a little bit last month
the treasury department estimates that
the historic release of oil by president
biden and international partners has
reduced gas prices by up to about 40
cents per gallon as we have shared with
you all last week
more work remains but the fact is that
we are currently experiencing the
fastest decline in gas prices in over a
decade
if a gambler loses his house at the
casino and then the next week wins back
a couple hundred bucks at the slot
machines
that does not mean that he is a winner
he is the opposite of a winner he is way
way
down
americans do not care how fast or slow
the gas prices change
they care
about what the gas prices are
the week joe biden took office the
average price of gasoline was two
dollars and 39 cents per gallon
six and a half months after joe biden
took office one year ago today
gas was three dollars and 17 cents per
gallon today do you know what it is
after the steepest decline of gas prices
ever in history today gas is four
dollars and 21 cents per gallon that
means that gas is 33 percent one-third
more expensive today than it was just a
year ago that means that gas is 76
more expensive today than it was the day
joe biden took office and by the way
those numbers are artificially low those
numbers are with joe biden currently
irresponsibly draining our strategic
petroleum reserve of one million barrels
of oil per day through the midterm
elections because he knows that
democrats are going to be punished at
the polls for his terrible policies as
well they should be i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from hugh jorgen
who says huge organ that's funny who
says i'm having a lot of fun uh
going to liberal media comment sections
and asking them why biden is building
portions of trump's border wall seeing
them lose their minds never gets old
that is such a great story and very very
few people are talking about it but joe
biden now caught between a rock and a
hard place desperately trying to
resurrect his
just dead poll numbers is now sort of
building part of trump's border wall
it's so great got to do it when you want
to build things especially help build
and fix things on your car you got to
check out rock auto right now head on
over to rockauto.com enter knowles in
their how did you hear about betis box
did you know that some states now have
laws that say as early as the 2030 model
year new vehicles will have to be
electric in order to be registered which
means that people are going to keep
repairing and driving their old cars for
generations also means you better go to
rockauto.com right now and order all the
parts that you need to properly maintain
and repair your car your great grandkids
might be driving that car someday it's
going to be like we're all living in
cuba the cars do look very nice there
not ideal conditions but the cars do
look very nice when you want to repair
your car you go to rock auto it's as
simple as that they've been in the auto
parts business for 20 years family owned
the goal is to make auto parts available
and affordable for everybody to keep you
safe on the road they achieve that goal
beautifully same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers no gimmicks
it's just easy you need brakes shocks
carpet wipers headlights mirrors
mufflers lug nuts any other parts you
need you go to rockauto.com enter
knowles in their how did you hear about
this box so they know that we sent you
do they think we're stupid do they think
we're idiots
do they when when the white house comes
out and says actually
we have great news on gas prices oh you
shouldn't complain about gas prices it's
all really great actually because the
decline over the past month has been big
you say okay the decline has been big
well in california gas was over eight
dollars a gallon so okay it declined a
little bit or even even if it declined a
lot the gas prices are still much much
higher than before biden took office and
much much higher than they were even a
year ago that's not good oh great think
you made things so bad that people just
couldn't afford gas at all so you had to
release a million barrels of oil a day
from the strategic reserve because of
your stupid policies not for the purpose
of the strategic petroleum reserve which
is in case of war which is in case of
some national emergency it's it's an
emergency that you joe biden created
because of your dumb energy policies and
your dumb foreign policy and now you're
trying to put a band-aid over that to
get you through the midterm elections
and even so the gas prices are through
the roof
and you want us you want to urinate on
our legs and tell us that it's raining
that's what they're doing they're
probably going to tell us it's global
warming or something like that
but we know i think people know a little
bit better than that and you saw it you
you saw it just yesterday when peter
ducey at the white house briefing was
talking to the president's spokesman
asked about this issue that my favorite
comment talked about which is this issue
of joe biden
after lambasting trump for the border
wall for the entire 2020 campaign now
building parts of the wall
why is the bidet administration building
a border wall in arizona
so um
we are not uh we're not finishing the
wall we are cleaning up the mess the
prior administration uh left behind in
their in their failed attempt uh to
build a wall what president biden when
he was a candidate said there will not
be another foot of wall constructed in
my administration so what changed we are
not finishing the wall
if
walls work in that part of arizona
is this the administration trying to get
migrants to cross
somewhere else like in texas what what
is the plan we are not finishing a wall
we are cleaning up the mess that the
prior administration made we are trying
to save lives this is what is this is
what the prior administration left
behind that we are now cleaning up
this girl karine jean-pierre is
not nearly as good at this as her
predecessor was jen saki jensaki was
fine at being a press secretary she
wasn't as good as some of the trump
administration press secretaries who
were some of the best that we'd had in
20 years but karine jean-pierre is
really really bad the job of a press
secretary very often is to deflect
so you get asked a question it's a tough
question you don't want to give the
answer so you deflect but you try to do
it in a way that is subtle that is
clever that makes it seem like you're
answering the question karine
jean-pierre can't do that
peter ducey asks a simple question he
says okay the biden administration is
building parts of trump's wall
biden said he would not build another
foot of wall now they are building parts
of trump's wall what changed she says
we're not finishing the wall
uh okay no one accused you of finishing
the wall we're asking why you're
building more of the wall we're not
finishing it
i i know you're not i understand that
when no one's suggested that you are
finished i'm not having a turkey
sandwich on wednesday morning
okay
that has no one raised that
no one raised that prospect at all i
want you to answer the question that i'm
asking you which is why is joe biden
currently building parts of the wall
we're cleaning up the mess the previous
administration made well okay
if you're saying that the border wall
that trump built
or partially built is a mess and you
want to clean up that mess
that means you would dismantle the wall
but the biden administration is not
dismantling the wall they're doing the
opposite they're building more of the
wall why are they building more of the
wall because the walls work why is biden
doing it right now after promising that
he wouldn't after democrats vilified the
wall for five years
biden is building more of that wall
because while mass migration
helps the democrats in the long term
because it changes the voting
demographics of the country in a way
that is advantageous to democrats maybe
not as advantageous as they hope it is
because hispanics are shifting
republican right now
but overall it does give democrats a
pretty major voting advantage so they
know in the long run that's going to
help them in the short run though it's
going to kill them because everyone
hates mass migration because it's
lawless
because it screws up labor markets
because it's a national security threat
because it causes all sorts of disorder
in
smaller communities border communities
right there near mexico because it leads
to a lot of drugs coming to the country
because it leads to a lot of constant a
lot of prostitution not a lot of
constitution a lot of prostitution leads
to a lot of gang activity so it's just
it's just awful and the mexican cartels
control the entire border if you want to
come into the country illegally you have
to go through the cartel so it
introduces organized crime in here
essentially a sort of paramilitary in
mexico it's just awful in the short run
the democrats know it's going to kill
them at the polls in november and so
they've got to try to do something about
it but the minute they do anything about
it they're going to admit that trump was
right so they can't do that so now
they're impotent they want to have their
cake and eat it
too this is what you're seeing right now
forget about the foreign policy with
mexico this is what you're seeing with
the foreign policy on the other side of
the world stunning stunning statement
yesterday from the pentagon under joe
biden's leadership john kirby the
pentagon spokesman came out and said in
no uncertain terms the united states
does not want independence for taiwan
we have repeatedly said
that we oppose any unilateral changes to
the status quo from either side
we have said that we do not support
taiwan independence
and we have said that we expect
cross-strait differences to be resolved
by peaceful means
we have communicated this directly to
the prc at the highest levels
the united states doesn't support taiwan
independence
the united states has supported taiwan
independence for what 80 years now or
something
a little less at 70 years
when the communists took power in china
the previous nationalist government in
china fled to taiwan so the official
position of the united states for many
many decades now is that taiwan is
really the legitimate government of
china and then when we started to
acknowledge that the communists had
entrenched themselves in power there we
we insisted upon the independence of
taiwan china has been trying to grab
taiwan now for a very long time and a
lot of the geostrategic maneuvering that
you're seeing is over the status of
taiwan and then all of a sudden joe
biden completely flips the script says
forget taiwan we don't care we don't
want it to be independent and actually
that's what we've said all along what
are you talking about bro we have the
receipts i have a tweet here from joe
biden from may 19 2020 while he's
running for president he says taiwan's
thriving democracy in response to covet
19 are an example to the world america's
support for taiwan
must remain strong principled and
bipartisan
until i'm elected president at which
point we're going to sell these people
down the river and sell america's
foreign policy down the river at every
single turn on domestic policy on
foreign policy everywhere joe biden can
look what do you get
weakness
weakness
weakness
when you want to feel strong when you
don't want to feel anemic you want to
have lots of nice iron pumping through
your body you've got to check out good
ranchers right now head on over to
goodranchers.com
knowles back to school season is upon us
and while some american kids are excited
to get back to the classroom i know a
lot of kids they're not so excited to go
back to school and you know why because
these children don't know where their
meals will be coming from this semester
but i do because i know that good
ranchers has made it their mission to
donate 100 000 high quality meals to
kids facing food insecurity and
malnourishment this fall semester it's a
really really wonderful thing to do even
for kids who are not facing these kinds
of problems they would be so lucky and
thrilled to know that they've got food
coming from good ranchers good ranchers
will donate a nutritious meal to a child
in need for every box ordered through
the month of august help them reach
their goal of 100 000 donated meals by
ordering your box today goodranchers.com
knowles good ranchers is a wonderful
award-winning american food company i
eat their stuff probably three days a
week at this point i just i adore it
great company right now use my code
knowles canon wles get 30 off your order
plus free shipping your purchase
furthers their mission to donate 100 000
high quality meals to children in need
it's a great cause it's great food go to
goodranchers.com knowles
make sure you use that code knowles when
you place your order and let's help
these guys hit their goal
joe biden's take on taiwan
is
perfectly precisely the opposite of the
foreign policy that you want
there's going to be a divide among
conservatives some conservatives are
going to want a robust defense of taiwan
those are going to be the more
interventionist types some conservatives
are going to say who cares about taiwan
let china have it those are going to be
the isolationist types
whichever side you are on or if you're
like most people somewhere in the middle
and you vacillate depending on the
circumstances regardless of where you
stand on foreign policy broadly
what i think everybody wants
is strength
you want to seem
strong
whether you use that force in foreign
adventurism or whether you don't use
that force you want the rest of the
world to fear you to stay in line to
believe that there is a credible threat
that you can use that force and then
when people believe that usually you
don't have to actually use it this is
why donald trump's foreign policy was so
insanely effective people said when
trump got elected he's a madman he's a
lunatic he's going to blow up the world
oh no he's tweeting at kim jong-un about
his big nuclear button that works he's
calling him fat oh no this is going to
blow up the world no it's it didn't
on on
every area of foreign policy when we're
talking about china
we're talking he finally got china to
make some trade concessions after
multiple administrations failed at that
on
israel and palestine oh my gosh he was
donald trump was so effective on peace
in the middle east they named a town
after him a train station and a town in
israel that's how effective he was took
out iran's top general ripped up that
stupid nuclear program that would have
given iran a
a nuclear weapon
he got saudi arabia to normalize
relations with israel or to begin to
normalize relations with israel he got
kim jong-un to back down even for
goodness sakes he visited the dmz donald
trump
he
on every area of foreign policy he was
so extremely effective why
is it because he was a huge
interventionist he wasn't really a huge
interventionist he ran as an anti-war
candidate he ran against the bush
administration legacy is it because he
was an isolationist he wasn't really an
isolationist either you remember when he
just droned out general sulaimani you
remember when he dropped the mother of
all bombs in the middle east i don't
even remember where in the middle east
he used it
trump was he was sometimes isolationist
he was sometimes interventionist overall
he was unpredictable
and he projected strength
foreign leaders actually domestic
leaders too just didn't know what trump
was going to do
and they knew that he was going to
project strength that was the one thing
they did know but they didn't know how
he would use it maybe he'd back off in a
certain area maybe he would go drop the
mother of all bombs maybe he'd click the
nuclear freaking button people just
didn't know and it kept everybody in
line this is like in in areas that have
strong protections for the second
amendment
areas where you have concealed carry
as a legal option
people tend to be a little bit more
polite okay
when you don't know who's packing you're
gonna be a little bit nicer
than in an area where you're in a
gun-free zone and then you you everybody
mouse off because you know there were no
threats with trump he was totally
unpredictable it was the best foreign
policy of my lifetime
including george h.w bush george h.w
bush for his
many faults as president
had a generally
relatively decent foreign policy much
better than the foreign policy of his
three immediate successors
clinton bush ii and obama
but trump's was better than than bush's
trump had this brilliant foreign policy
because he projected strength and
therefore he didn't need to use it
joe biden constantly projects weakness
that's why we might need to use it in
ukraine he projected weakness vladimir
zelinski blames joe biden for the
russian invasion of ukraine
on taiwan he's projecting weakness
what's going to happen
certainly china is going to continue to
aggress in taiwan taiwan is already
calling troops up as though they need to
prepare for war
the total on every it's unbelievable how
perfectly you can count on how perfectly
wrong biden's decisions will be and
people know it joe biden's sixth quarter
approval ratings according to gallup are
the lowest
ever recorded ever not just in a decade
not just in two decades not just for
this quarter just ever okay his approval
rating has sunk to 38 percent
in the gallup survey this is the lowest
approval rating of his presidency
and the lowest approval rating in
gallup's 74-year history
so what can the democrats do
they're going to try to gin up a bunch
of contrived fake stuff they're going to
try to bring covid back they're going to
try to lock down they're going to try to
encourage widespread mail-in ballots
because it's easier to cheat they're
going to try to turn election day into
election month or election season
and they're they're also going to to
encourage a recession and they're going
to encourage a recession because you
need to get through the recession to
come out of the recession and if joe
biden is going to lose some democrats in
2022 he'd rather put himself in a better
position for 2024 but you are going to
see
desperate desperate moves the the one
desperate action that the dems have been
trying to gin up for 2022 is this
january 6th committee and and they've
been holding this kangaroo court and
they've been trying their political
opponents without a defense present and
they they are now the federal
prosecutors are even throwing people
in prison which we'll get to in a second
how is this playing though how is this
playing well cnn just went up to wyoming
to interview liz cheney's constituents
liz cheney a nominal republican who is
for all intents and purposes a democrat
now and not just any democrat she's a
very vocal democrat who is the face of
the january 6th hearings because she
hates donald trump and and donald
trump's voters namely half the country
so they went up to wyoming and said okay
do you do you intend to vote for liz
cheney and her principled true
conservative leadership on the january
6th hearings take a listen
at frontier days in cheyenne wyoming we
found plenty of republican voters
bucking the cheney name and vowing not
to support congresswoman liz chaney for
her fourth term are you planning to vote
for liz cheney
can i cuss
hell no
are you planning to support liz cheney
absolutely not what are your thoughts
about liz chaney running for a fourth
term
um personally i think she said for three
too many keep in mind in 2020 donald
trump won about 70 percent of the vote
in wyoming so liz cheney's work on the
january 6 investigation isn't playing so
well with many wyoming voters she's done
us dirty
how so
oh god
look what how she's done trump
i'm a i'm a trump fan i'm sorry so she
lost your vote because of her role on
the january 6 committee and what she's
doing about trump yes
she's supposed to be supporting him
she's a republican for crying out loud i
find her work on the january 6th
committee just repulsive how do you feel
about her work on the january 6
committee in her role it's all a hoax
it's all propaganda has nothing to do
with anything it's a witch hunt
fact check true love those voters great
job man i i need to get a vacation home
in wyoming we got to sell more blank
books so that i can buy a vacation home
and i can do it in wyoming because those
people have the right idea and liz
cheney has the wrong idea and cnn is
showing that that's the most interesting
part here cnn has spent the last year
building up liz cheney because liz
cheney has spent the last year more than
the last year attacking her fellow
republicans and attacking donald trump
so cnn loves that and they built up liz
cheney
if you talk to your liberal friends and
relatives right now i guarantee you they
will say you know i'm no republican but
i like that liz cheney she's principled
she puts country over party she and
they'll recite a bunch of completely
meaningless platitudes and they will do
that because liz cheney is effectively a
liberal democrat now and that's the side
that she's supporting and that's that's
who is building her up for the last year
and a half or multiple years and now
they're shipping her why is cnn airing
this absolutely humiliating segment
for liz cheney
they're doing it because cnn can score
more points by throwing liz cheney under
the bus than they now can by building
her up
they can now say these trump voters are
out of their minds they're
pro-insurrection they love january 6.
look liz cheney she did her best and
they hate her she's a joke she's gonna
get kicked out now because the the goal
was always to attack republicans was
always to attack conservatives was
always to attack trump when liz cheney
was useful to them to do that when she
was the court jester in the kingdom of
liberalism they built her up and they
used her but now she's no longer useful
now it's more useful to throw her under
the bus and so they are going to do that
this is a lesson to everyone this is a
lesson i am on my knees pleading with
you conservatives republicans
do not squish
do not become liz cheney it doesn't pay
you know some people you'll hear this in
school drugs not even once crime doesn't
pay stay on the straight and narrow
that's what i'm telling you about not
squishing do not squish
squishing is the wrong thing to do it's
disloyal it's morally idiotic if you're
siding with the democrats who want to
kill babies and trans the little kids
and put drag queen story hour in
kindergarten if you're on that team i'm
just telling you you are on the wrong
team whatever the flaws of the
conservatives and the republicans if
you're on the team of transiting the
kids and killing the babies you're on
the wrong team okay so it's wrong
objectively to side with those people
but as a political matter it never pays
they will always kill you in the end
they are not on your side they are using
you and when you are no longer useful
you will be discarded and you will have
no one absolutely no one to come to your
aid because you're a rat and a traitor
if you do that do not squish have i made
myself clear i hope so recently we
celebrated the one year anniversary of
our podcast morning wire
in that short period of time it has
become one of the top news podcasts i
suspect that is because morning wire
gives you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less without the
manufactured outrage new episodes are
available every morning seven days a
week and they cover the most important
stories of the day so check out morning
wire on apple podcast spotify daily wire
plus or wherever you listen to podcasts
we'll be right back with a lot more
speaking of disloyalty this story is so
sad a january sixther has just been
sentenced to seven years in prison
and he's been sentenced to seven years
in prison
after his son his 19 year old son turned
on him turned him in testified against
him
i actually remember this story when it
first bubbled up in the media many
months ago this is guy refit
49 years old convicted of five felonies
in march
and now looking at seven years in prison
the son 19 year old son said that that
he was disgusted by his father showing
up to the capitol in washington d.c
on january 6th i don't even know that
the father ever even went inside the
capitol i think he may have just been on
the capitol
grounds the sun was disgusted by this
the sun said that the father threatened
him and his sister if they turned him in
the sister contradicts this narrative
the sister sided with the father
the son testified against the father
what's so sad about this is not only the
two-tier justice system
because if if the father had instead
been up on charges related to much worse
charges
at a blm rally forget about the capital
january 6th if the this guy guy refit
had done 10 times whatever he did at the
capitol on behalf of the blm
organization he
he probably wouldn't have been arrested
he probably wouldn't have been certainly
wouldn't have been charged maybe a
little slap on the wrist from the
officer don't do that again he'd be
right back on the street but because
he's a trump supporter he's looking at
seven years in the can that's not even
the worst part we know about the
two-tier justice system what is so
sickening to me about this story
is the the destruction of this family
that this
political movement
by which i'm talking about the left
has turned a family
against each other
i'm not just talking about i'm not
saying that the the right wing is
blameless or the one
but i but i am saying this is being
driven by the left
okay the january sixth
witch hunt the show trial the
selective prosecutions the two-tier
justice system has created such
political pressure and demonized
half the country as terrorists and
insurrectionists and traitors and
threats to the country
that
you've now got families pitted against
each other a son testifying against his
father which is what the liberals want
that is what the libs are after they are
after the destruction of the family they
are after the destruction of the family
because the family is the impediment to
their power
because the family is the fundamental
political unit
the libs believe that the fundamental
political unit is the individual
that's what they want it to be when you
can break down all of society into just
individuals then it's much easier to
gobble them all up into a collective
leftist political movements have known
this for
centuries
the conservatives believe that the
fundamental unit of society is not the
individual it's the family that's why we
support not only the family but other
associations and civic institutions
because those are mediating
mediating institutions between the
individual and the all-encompassing
state
and the libs want to destroy that and
the basic one they want to destroy is
the family this is why you're seeing the
groomer movement from the left this is
why you're seeing the left go into
elementary schools and say hey kids talk
to us about sex don't talk to your
families about sex hey your name's not
really johnny your name's jane now i'm
going to call you jane i'm not going to
call you he i'm going to call you she
we're going to get you on cross-sex
hormones don't tell your parents
we're going to pass laws that that will
allow us to groom you in this sexual way
without ever notifying your parents
we're going to pass laws to allow you to
kill your children through abortion and
never have to notify your parents we
want to get between the child and the
parents we think that the parents the
family is a terrible influence on the
kids we think that we the state are a
good influence on the kids so that's why
we're going to suppress the family and
we're going to encourage the growth of
the state that's what you see in
abortion what is abortion it's the
clearest sort of policy to destroy the
family you're literally killing the kids
you are killing the possibility of the
family this is why you see the articles
every time thanksgiving or christmas
rolls around all these left-wing
articles how to talk to your crazy
conservative uncle at the table even
though you ha you have to talk to him
and here's how here's how you can get
through that conversation and convince
him to be a leftist and i say this i am
a crazy conservative uncle i am the
uncle they're talking about okay so i
know i've had these conversations
you don't see that from from the right
very rarely do you see from the right
how to talk to your lesbian transgender
left-wing cousin at the dinner table we
just we say how do you talk to your your
left-wing relatives the same way you
talk to your right-wing relatives you
treat them like your family because
blood is thicker than water and blood is
thicker than the cnn airwaves okay
that's what conservatives believe
the left wing thinks that political
ideology trumps every single thing else
and they look at the family as the enemy
it's a consistent pattern here
and so
when when a family is destroyed because
of this january 6th stuff
no one's blameless i'm not saying any
any political movement is totally
pristine and angelic that doesn't exist
in politics but this is being driven by
the left and when that happens the left
is a giddy to watch a family break up
you want to talk about family there's a
story i meant to get to yesterday
sydney sweeney
is an actress on the handmaid's tale
you probably have not watched the
handmaid's tale i have not i did watch a
few of the first episodes just to see
what it was about i couldn't keep
watching it was just so it just seems
kind of like
soft core porn for women just seems like
kind of these weird sexual fantasies
that women have that is that's not based
on reality it's not it's not we're not
living in anything like the handmaid's
tale in america but but women have this
kind of fantasy that we are sort of like
50 shades of grey so i said okay this is
too weird i'm not going to keep watching
this but sydney sweeney apparently is
one of the actresses on handmaid's tale
and she just came out
and complained about the way that
hollywood treats women and she didn't
complain about it in the usual way
and she didn't complain about it about
the treatment of women in the way you
might expect from the handmaid's tale
which is that the conservatives and the
patriarchy and the right wing is
oppressing women no it was the opposite
it was that leftism
feminism
is harming women
she says
i want to have a family i've always
wanted to be a young mom
and i'm worried about how this industry
puts stigmas on young women who have
children and looks at them in a
different light
i was worried that if i don't work
there's no money and no support for kids
that i would have
she made this complaint to amy adams
and amy adams told her now it can be
done you can have kids at a young age
but the insecurities over her financial
health and the momentum of her career
remain years later this this young woman
i think is 24 she's in her mid-20s
somewhere
very very sad how confused she is
and it's and it's very sad that that
hollywood does put the stigma on women
who have families
it's almost as if
the real threats to women
are not coming from the conservatives
they're coming from the leftists it's
almost as if the handmaid's tale is
depicting the opposite of reality it's
almost as if feminism isn't really good
for women it's almost as if ever since
the advent of feminism in the 1970s
modern feminism you've seen women's
happiness consistently decline both in
absolute terms and relative to men
it's almost as if leftism is a total
psyop and it's making women completely
miserable
a family would make this woman happy
it's it's not just me making an
observation she knows that too and she
feels that she can't support the family
why not well she says what if i don't
make enough money i can't work and
that's an amazing statement
she's a beautiful successful young woman
did it never occur to her that when she
has a child
she would be she would do that in a
marriage
and that her husband might work and be
able to support her while she's taking
care of her child
it's amazing this woman believes that
she is going to have to carry the burden
entirely herself she's going to have to
make all the money she's going to have
to care for the kid entirely herself
she's going to have to continue to work
and she's they're not going to want her
to work because hollywood doesn't like
mothers hollywood doesn't like families
hollywood likes people to remain 19
years old forever
and and when women age they want to
encourage them to pretend to be 19 years
old forever
it's never occurred to her and i bet
that's true for a lot of women
but ladies there is another option
you could get married you could take
care of your kid not all of life is
about money not all of life of life is
about looking young forever not all of
life is about what feminism tells you
life is about
and and the real oppression the real
things that are making you miserable
it's not coming from those right wingers
it's not coming from the people they
tell you to fear it's coming from your
own side speaking of female performers
linda sanchez democrat congress lady
from california
was just at the congressional baseball
game
an event that i always liked to attend
if i was in washington d.c i try to go
to the congressional baseball game and
it's fun you got the democrats versus
the republicans they're generally
terrible at baseball
some of the some of the guys are a
little bit better than others but it's
fun to go out there you got the staffers
from the republicans and the democrats
show up they go to national stadium and
at this baseball game usually people are
kind of having fun and it's a good time
to drop all the partisan ranker well
this lady couldn't drop it linda sanchez
she's running maybe i don't know if she
got thrown out or struck out or whatever
she's running back and she goes past the
republican dugout and she flips off the
republicans
to lead off the inning we'll get a pinch
runner down there the fist bump
we'll get an eye on who the pinch runner
is going to be looks like it's going to
be so it wasn't even that was just a
pinch runner so she goes she hits she's
on base to a nice ovation she's jogging
back past the republican dugout there
she goes she flips him off
that's not very nice so she flips them
off that's not really in the spirit of
the congressional base baseball game
that lady wasn't raised right and then
when she gets called out for it
she denies it and she says no no i
wasn't flipping off the team
it was an obnoxious fan who shouts
misogynistic s-h-i-t at me every single
year she said no it wasn't i was just
reacting to someone else and she knew
she couldn't blame the republicans in
the dugout because there were cameras on
them and you could see none of the
republicans were doing that and so she
said no it was a fan behind them so then
the reporters said okay well who's the
fan what did the fan forget even who's
the fan what did the fan say and she
says i'm not going to dignify it with a
response because it's
nasty and it's crude and it has no place
at a charity baseball game so it's bs
she's completely making it up she
flipped off the republicans and then she
got called out for it because it didn't
play as well as she thought it would and
then she blamed it on a rowdy fan then
she refused to give any details about
the fan it's just it's just made up
this is such a classic
lib strategy they do this all the time
they pretend that their aggression is
defensive
they pretend that when they go out and
they clobber you and they beat you up
and they burn down your businesses and
they shut down your country and they
attack private citizens just use blm as
an example they say no that's defensive
we're protecting ourselves
because
a a drug addict career criminal resisted
arrest and was killed in a police
in a police-involved killing in an
altercation where he was resisting
arrest so now we're going to burn the
country down for eight months well
that's just defensive we're not being
the aggressive ones we're being
defensive uh yes we're going to go into
the schools we're going to transgender
all your kids we're going to put gay
porn in your elementary school libraries
but that's defensive because of our
homophobic culture
because of our transphobic culture those
trans-homophobic parents that's why
we've got to go in and chop off your
kids genitals
it's defensive
we got to go we're going to kill your
babies
everyone we got to kill all our babies
in america that's defensive
you see it's the babies they're the
aggressive ones
because they're threatening your career
and your money and your individual
autonomy
they always pretend that their
aggression
is
defensive
maybe we should get a little bit
aggressive i'm not saying in the libway
in the blm way where we burn down the
country maybe we should get a little
aggressive in the political order maybe
we should start flexing a little
political power that's what indiana is
doing
the indiana state senate
just passed a bill that bans virtually
all abortions
uh this is the first such ban to be
advanced
since dobbs so the dobbs decision comes
down
roe v wade overruled planned parenthood
v casey overruled in a number of states
they had trigger laws in effect such
that when
roe is overruled those states would
outlaw most abortions but this is the
first state that has gone out and
created a new law in the world post row
in the world post dobbs decision that
says okay now we're going to ban
abortions
this is really great news and you know
what the effect of that's going to be
fewer abortions because when you pass a
law that allows something you get more
of it and when you pass a law that bans
something you get less of it
there are some ideologues who try to
deny that reality but that's the way
things actually work
and as a result
you're going to get more of a culture of
life less of a culture of death you are
going to see
as i've suggested a number of times on
this show though some conservatives
don't like to hear it
very often culture is downstream of
politics when we flex the political
power in a just way that we are given by
the people that can have wonderful
effects on the culture by the way we
don't even need to pass new laws in a
lot of cases we can just resurrect old
ones
in michigan
the michigan court has just ruled that a
1931 abortion ban can go into effect
there's a
1931 abortion ban that obviously when
roe v wade came out that law was nixed
because the the supreme court said okay
all the pro-life laws are dead now you
have a right to an abortion
so michigan's local prosecutors after
the dobbs decision just came out and
tried to enforce the state's abortion
ban
this was temporarily blocked by a judge
in may now the michigan court of appeals
has ruled that that preliminary
injunction blocking the law does not
apply to county prosecutors so the count
the county prosecutors in michigan can
prosecute people
can prosecute abortionists can prosecute
people who are who are peddling abortion
and killing little kids using that 1931
law what this reminds me is
it was not so long ago that we had a
normal country
1931 it's not that long ago it's less
than 100 years ago
it was not so long ago that we just
people just knew even in places that we
now consider blue states we just know
yeah killing babies is wrong we can all
agree on that
and then the left very rapidly tried to
change everything and they very often
did it using the mechanism of the
supreme court
which was
which was quick at the time it was done
in haste but it didn't win over that
public opinion and what's done in haste
can be undone in haste
you think about this a lot of
conservatives now they're just they're
just total losers they just they want to
lose they don't want to win
losers never win as
as has been attributed to donald trump
that wonderful quote losers never win
okay so
people will say we're never going to
overrule row we're never going to get
back to a normal definition of marriage
we're never going to get
the the bible or prayer in schools again
we're that's such a that's a pipe dream
you crazy oh you're living in the past
man that's a pipe dream it's not a pipe
dream it wasn't so long ago
it wasn't so long ago that people were
normal a lot of people still are normal
and even if people were were swayed in
the middle of the 20th century by some
of these crazy liberal arguments we've
now seen them play out
even if people might have said look a
little more sexual liberation maybe
that's fine we see where that ends that
ends at transiting the kids people say
whoa
okay i don't want that learn my lesson
i'm going back
people see we're well maybe we allow
abortion in a few limited circumstances
we see where that ends almost a million
dead babies per year
oh man we don't want that we're going to
go back okay what's done in haste can be
undone in haste we can flex that power a
lot of these things are on the books
already before we go
major news story out of pop culture
beyonce is changing the lyrics to her
song heated
haven't listened to the song haven't
listened to the album
she's changing the lyrics
because she uses an ableist
term
that
some people are saying is very offensive
to the handicapped community and so
beyonce has come out and she said okay
i'm going to change the word
to the song i have not listened to the
song i've just printed out the lyrics
here i'm just going to read you one
stanza from the song
you tell me what's wrong with the stanza
never met a girl so fine like this no no
no no no fan me off i'm hot hot hot with
a waste that whine like this y-w-h-i-n-e
tip-tip tip on hardwood floors 10 10 10
across the board with a waist that whine
like this give me face face face face
face yeah
your face card never declines
eat it eat it eat it eat it eat it
yummy yummy yum make the bummy heated
make a pretty girl talk s-h-i-t-t-y
whiskey till i'm tipsy glitter on my
kitty ooh cool it down down down my
pretty
bad bad
b-i-t-c-h-e make that bad b-i-t-ch
glitchy fine fine fine fine fine fine
fine for mine liberated living like we
ain't got time yada yada yada ya ya ya
i'm not saying that that's actually in
the lyrics
spazzin on that ass spasm on that ass
fan me quick girl i need my glass fan me
off my wrist goes click dimples on my
hip stretch marks on my tits drink in my
water mind in my biz
monday i'm overrated tuesday on my dick
and and then it actually somehow sort of
gets worse i'll just leave it there
the reason that she has to change the
words is because of the word spazz
everything else is totally fine the
problem with the song is the word spazz
and they're saying it's ableist which is
ridiculous because obviously whoever
wrote this song is extremely mentally
deficient so i don't see how in any way
this could be called ableist but that's
the word you're not allowed to use that
word spazz this is apparently offensive
to
some disabled people
so the song will have that word changed
it will remain
absolute degenerate filth
but that one word is going to be
switched out
what a sad
statement on our culture that's what's
wrong with the song that's how is this
even a song i don't know how you could
even call this
a song
very very sad that we are living in in
that culture
very very that's it don't you think it's
a little misogynistic by the way not to
sound like a lib don't you think it's a
little offensive to women treating women
just like sex objects or men like sex
objects don't you think it's a little
vulgar and obscene and just no
it's just that it's
offensive to [ __ ] people
how do you get to a culture like this
how do you how do you get to a culture
like he did
like like whatever beyonce is singing
about
part of it is just something in the air
something in the water something in the
zeitgeist but a lot of this is from
politics a lot of this is from the law
the law is a teacher okay and
the sexual revolution
was not just a cause of the changes in
law the law the changes in law was a
cause of the sexual revolution as well
okay and so if if conservatives want to
uh
want to change more of these lyrics not
just the ableist lyrics but all of them
if we want to get back to a culture that
is not just so degraded and treats
people like absolute
animals and starts treating people like
people again and it actually has some
beauty to it and poetry and lifts our
eyes up a little bit beyond just the
things that are flapping and dapping and
yaya ya on the floor with the face face
face if if we want to have a culture
that is edifying and flourishing we've
got to take on this issue the libs
always say why are conservatives so
obsessed with sex we're the ones
obsessed with sex you're the ones
pushing this crap you're the ones
pushing all these laws and grooming the
kids and putting sex everywhere in the
culture you're the ones doing that
because you know that it is so extremely
effective at
pulling out people's
lowest basest appetites you know it's so
central to human nature you know it's it
is so influential on political society
maybe we need to start wielding
political power
in the opposite way that the libs did
for the last century to try to restore a
more normal culture otherwise we're
going to be
spazzing and flapping and yapping and
doing all sorts of stuff and that that
will not be good for anybody i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show nancy
pelosi prepares to visit taiwan as the
chinese threaten war the military kills
ayman al-zawahiri with a drone strike
but why exactly is he in kabul and
beyonce is forced to change her lyrics
thanks to political correctness that's
sedan the bench bureau show give it a
listen